hello and welcome to my first leaders
briefing of 2023 I hope everyone had a
fantastic Christmas and a really good
relaxing break and obviously Happy New
Year I know it's a bit late in the year
to be saying that now but obviously best
wishes for a healthy and happy and
prosperous 2023 now New Years are always
a really good time to both look back and
reflect on the year that's gone and also
to look forward in terms of what's going
to come come our way in 2023 so I
thought I'd just take a few minutes to
talk about some of our key achievements
over the past year and also look ahead
to what's coming in the next few months
so 2022 was an incredibly busy year for
the council and I'm delighted at how
many things we were able to achieve so
just to name a few we were able to
secure our Gold Award as part of the
ministry of defense's employer
recognition scheme which is a part of
the Armed Forces Covenant and that was
all about how fantastic an employer we
are in particular for people from the
Armed Forces community and reservists we
also celebrated the completion of the
400th home as part of our external wall
insulation scheme our green homes scheme
which is fantastic to do and we
celebrated in eckington with a tenant
there completing that 400th property our
fantastic previous chair of the council
councilor Martin Thacker raised almost
80 000 pounds for ashgate hospice care
which is the most on record we think
that any chairman of this Council in the
past 40 years has raised for any any
charity so really fantastic achievement
there we also rolled out began the
rollout of CCTV in our in our taxi
services which is a really important way
it's backed by the department for
transport and it's a really important
way of ensuring that both the drivers
and the customers are safe and kept safe
moving forward we've also updated our
climate change strategy and and provided
more information to our communities
about how you can support us in dealing
with the issues of climate change and
reducing our carbon emissions and we did
a huge amount of work uh in particularly
in the past few months around the cost
of living crisis and supporting our
residents and businesses to help deal
with the impacts particularly in terms
of advice around energy saving tips and
all of those sorts of things and there's
still a wealth of information on our
website so do please check that out if
if you need any any help whatsoever and
obviously if you or anyone you know
needs any help please don't hesitate to
contact the council
but one of the biggest things I think in
terms of 2022 was our massive investment
in Leisure we started the Year by
opening eckington Leisure Center up
after a period of closure while we did a
1.5 million pound investment in the
facility and that was to completely
realign the pool it was to install SOS
heat pumps and solar panels on the roof
as part of the government's public
sector decarbonisation scheme and then
almost straight away after that we were
able to secure another Grant from the
government of 1.3 million to do very
similar works at drumfield sports center
and those works are now very near in
completion and again we've put solar
panels on the roof and air source heat
pumps as well as a few internal
improvements
we also were delighted back in the
Autumn to open killer Marsh active after
a 1.9 million pound refurbishment
project there and the center is doing
fantastically well membership is
continuing to rise it's a great facility
now for the community in killer Marsh
after a long period of of basically
declining the sports center and very
difficult Financial circumstances for
the parish council there and then
finally we've also now had planning
permission approval of and we've
approved the funding for and commenced
the contract for Charlie Park Leisure
Center a brand new 23 million pound
Leisure Center in Clay Cross in the
heart of Clay Cross as part of the Town
deal so that's work's going to start
there in the next month or so we'll be
doing Spades in the ground and and we're
absolutely delighted that that project
is now up and off the ground after being
talked about for many many years so
really pleased with that and I think
that's a great way to finish off at 20
22 which was a fantastic year for the
council and one in which we we achieved
a heck of a lot now moving on to 2023
and sticking with the theme of leisure
after the huge amount of investment we
put into our Leisure centers over the
past few years it's also worth
highlighting that there's loads of
activities happening across our four
Leisure centers within the district now
particularly we've got half term coming
up I know as a parent myself it can be
quite challenging trying to find things
to do to keep the kids occupied but we
would really encourage everyone to visit
our website and check out all of the
really fun activities we've got across
the four Leisure centers particularly
during that half term week for parents
who are desperate for some sort of
business help and support in keeping the
kids entertained so please do check out
the website and have a look there on for
more information we've also been working
with an organization called Parkinson's
UK and we've been our Healthy Lifestyles
instructors have been going through
training with Parkinson's UK in order to
help make sure that they can deliver
their sessions in particular in a more
Parkinson's friendly way a so really
good good news there that we've got uh
good training for our staff to be able
to support people with those conditions
and really make our our services
absolutely as inclusive as possible and
then finally on the theme of leisure
it's worth highlighting that we know
that people are feeling the pinch at the
moment everyone is is dealing with the
impacts of the cost of living crisis so
it's really important that the council's
taking the decision to freeze Leisure
membership fees we know how important
Health you know health and well-being is
to our residents and how access to uh
you know reasonable priced Leisure
membership to how important that is and
how well valued our Leisure centers are
so we felt it was the right thing to do
and really important that we kept
Leisure prices at that lower level and
and obviously support residents to
continue to access them
now councilor Roth is also hosting as
chair of the council a number of events
over the next uh next few months in
support of her chairs charity which this
year is safer the Armed Forces uh
charity so she's having a race night
coming up we've got an Easter Wildlife
family fun day and a family fun day here
at our offices at Mill Lane which will
have an armed forces theme and a focus
and it'll be a great day out for all the
family so please do keep a lookout on
our website for more details of all the
events that Diana is hosting in support
of this fantastic cause which we know
does so much for the Armed Forces
community
now recently we issued a fixed penalty
notice to a resident who whose
fly-tipped waist had been found in
eckington and I just wanted to highlight
that as part of a string of quite high
profile prosecutions we've had around
fly tipping we absolutely take a zero
tolerance policy on fly tipping and it's
part of a range of activity that we've
been doing over the past few years to
really crack down on on fly tipping so
for example we've had a we've had a high
profile seizure and crushing of a
vehicle that was proven to have been
involved in Flight tipping we raised the
fines to the maximum possible amount
that we're allowed to issue in in law
we've started to deploy CCTV so mobile
CCTV and in known flight tipping hot
spots to try and catch the perpetrators
and then our our fantastic environmental
health Team we've increased the capacity
of that team and they're actually doing
more patrols than they've ever done on
than they've ever done before so in the
previous year year last year 2022 they
did a record number of patrols and they
issued a record number of fixed penalty
notices and the impact of that is
already being seen in the figures so I
think last year based on the previous
year reportings of flight tipping were
down 37 and they're down from the 2019
level of 20 so there's a big Drop In
Flight tipping reportings but that being
said any amount of fly tipping is too
much frankly and we really do have a
zero tolerance policy on it so if you do
see any fly tipping you can report it on
our website on the myself service Pages
or you can ring us up and report it that
way and obviously we will always come
out as quickly as we possibly can to
clear the waste and also if there's any
evidence of of who's been tipping the
waste we'll always follow that up and
the message to anyone thinking about fly
tipping or littering which is just as
bad in our districts is don't do it
because we will catch you and there will
be consequences to pay
now moving on to a bit more positive
news we've recently found out that the
government have approved our
applications for the Town Center
regeneration projects under the Clay
Cross Town deal that's really exciting
news we submitted the bids just before
Christmas and we found out from
government that they're happy for us to
proceed so we're doing a bit of
consultation at the moment and for the
next few weeks just to really hear back
from both residents and businesses
locally about our proposals for the Town
Center in terms of the creation of a
Market Square and all the Fantastic
things to go with that so please do look
on our website and on the clay Crosstown
deal website for more information about
those proposals it's also worth
highlighting that we're we're taking
another step forward in terms of Charlie
Park Leisure Center that's getting off
the ground now and works should start in
the next in the next few weeks or the
next month or so on that and we've also
approved the railway station feasibility
project which is the first step towards
a longer mission of trying to get a
railway station back to the Clay Cross
area so some good news all around on the
on the town deal and please do check out
our website and the town deal website to
keep keep up to date with the latest
latest news on that front and then
finally just on the topic of leveling up
and improving our district we found out
late last year that we've been awarded
2.58 million pounds from the
government's UK shared Prosperity fund
and that's an allocation to the district
council for us to invest in our
communities and really try and ensure
that the the benefits of leveling up are
felt right across the district so with
the our allocation of UK share
Prosperity fund we're doing a range of
things including investing in parks and
play areas and we know how valued they
are by by local families also investing
in shop Frontage and public realm Works
to try and improve the image and the
Aesthetics about some of our town
centers and Village centers and we're
also investing in Village Halls there's
an application process at our open at
the moment for Village Hall committees
and Parish councils to bid in for
important funding towards Village Hall
refurbishments and there's another round
of the parks and play areas fund open as
well for Parish councils to bid in for
we've allocated 640 000 pounds to
support parish and town councils to to
invest in their parks and play areas so
I really would encourage anyone who's
interested in those schemes to to get on
the website and find out more about how
to apply now as well as supporting
parish and town councils to invest in
parks and play areas we're also
investing quite heavily in some of our
own at the moment so of all the parks
and play areas around the district
there'll be several that are parish and
Town Council run but we also as a
district council have some that we're
responsible for and so we recently
completed an 80 000 pound refurbishment
of the filmere drive play area in
dronfield it's fantastic I've already
seen it myself it's all brand new
equipment new flooring and everything
and I'm sure that will be really enjoyed
by all the local residents who have told
me and you know many occasions while out
knocking on doors that something really
needed to be done with that Park so
thanks very much for for watching hope
you've enjoyed and found all the
information useful in this Leader's
briefing obviously it goes without
saying please do keep checking our
website and our social media channels
for more information there's lots going
on in Northeast Derbyshire and I'm sure
at 2023 will absolutely be as busy as
2022 has been and look forward to
sharing with you more and for more
important information and updates in the
next briefing thanks very much